hello and welcome I am - Moore and I'm
joined by Leonard and Nitai from
obsidian you guys have got an exciting
game coming out the outer worlds first
of all my first question is how does it
feel to have a game out that is one
letter away from being another game
weird I expected we should have seen
that one coming I guess could you the
hardest battle is the SEO battle on
Google so what we're going to do is
we're gonna jump into the game we have a
save already ready for us on my
controller on and so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna jump into the game we
have a save ready and then effectively
we're gonna let you guide us sure you
guys can take us towards the coolest
things let us see what you think is
exciting for you guys and for the
viewers to see I've been playing about
this game and I'm having a good time
I like Parvati a lot awesome she's one
of my favorite characters she has a line
which she basically just saves her age
but it's like the comedic delivery on it
it's just absolutely phenomenal new
thing is actually birch - yeah yeah took
me a little while to kind of figure out
yeah she's just a perfect voice for a
Parvati at this point yeah yeah I
enjoyed I I I'm enjoying like the
comedic performances which is something
that not a lot of games can pull off but
like importantly it's not just like the
performance is the Ryung is super strong
so far so good stuff on that so we are
here in front of a respek machine I
believe yeah we're gonna spend some
money and we're gonna let you guys
decide how to spec this character do you
have any particular gosh that's a lot of
points there's a lot of points someone
was playing a lot recently we want to
shoot things and we want to talk to
people so I feel like range and dialogue
can be very good we yeah we good ranged
for let's say 10 and then dialogue
another 10/10 let's go and get some
leadership skills going to okay so we're
gonna bring commands along you want
leadership exactly so a lot of these are
gonna be familiar to people like melee
ranged offense stealth but for people
who perhaps may not be super familiar
with your lineage of games what the kind
of is the impact of stuff like dialog
and leadership specifically is one
that's new right yeah leadership is
better use of your companions
inspiration I believe I get them
confused sometimes inspiration if you
have the twenty unlock you can use your
companion commands you can't always in
other builds you can always use your
computing your companions will be with
you in the fight but you can't
specifically tell them to attack as
their use their special abilities yeah
so I mean if you're just trying to
figure out a good build for this game is
very hard to go wrong with leadership 20
with Parvati as your favorite leadership
20 is their little hammer of Thor
ability yeah I'm so always nice to have
that of course the dialogue is a way to
get more finished some quests through
dialogue get more information get more
lore right so is is about catering your
style so my actual my main character is
a stealth person stealth and charisma
because and also a little bit defense
you can sneak around and if you get
caught talk your way out of it exactly
that's my plan
that's my yeah that's I love using that
with our disguise system it's pretty fun
yeah so my main character I'm actually
playing a character who's based on Simon
Phoenix from the movie demolition man
are you familiar with it yes we have
literally had that movie mentioned like
30 minutes ago and a drive to how weird
is that really yes in reference to like
some game that I hope it was a reference
to it being the greatest movie of all
time so I was looking for a place that
was quiet I figured the kitchen will be
louder than the hold so here I am cozy
like ain't it
okay so poverty is one of my favorite
characters currently one because it's a
familiar voice Ashly Burch who is it
took me a little while to place and I
had to actually have you guys tell me
too but also yeah she seems like very
she's the eager adventurer type and like
very wholesome kind of person yeah
that's a good way to put it yeah she
seems she seems interesting so what
we're gonna do is head down here which I
believe will let us land on a planet
which is called it's we're going to the
groundbreaker actually it's a space
station okay
okay it's a space thing yes there you
get around the right here we go let's go
relatively neutral territory relatively
yeah I'll see what we can do about that
yeah you're gonna have to go through
customs yeah I think I'm also over
encumbered by the looks of it yeah we
can get another companion on the way
back or you can drop some extra weapons
yeah I might actually just I'm actually
just trough some stuff
Wow yes somebody who really someone
really likes a triplet that's good it's
like finding an attic full of dolls I'm
sorry I just break them down instead of
dropping yeah you get at least get the
weapon parts yeah I get the weapon parts
I just told accent oh yeah there we go
and since you took some engineering
that's actually useful for you yeah on
each side of this got a doll
corporal wheeler yeah
this is a really cool ongoing thing that
I like everyone thinking that he's
hawthorn sometimes not believing you
know why he was Jake Joe Joe Cooper okay
but we're going for her go for it let's
see what happens if you try and run with
a fake ID okay this one captain
Hawthorne you said let me apologize in
advance I'm about to ruin your day
let's feel some in according to ship's
record you've been flagged by the board
your ship will be impounded until such a
time as they see fit to lift it but
we've hardly been out of Edgewater long
enough to get in trouble now hold on
this isn't the end of the world probably
how do I get this Rosanna take it up
with Odom Bedford a character is a
representative here on ground rigor his
office is located along the starboard
wall of the promenade shines like a
Byzantium commode can't miss it
access to that information is above my
pay grade and I've turned down three
promotions so it stays that way
I shouldn't be mentioning it but what
the hell this year impounding your ship
it doesn't happen much the board knows
we don't take kindly to their
interfering in our operations if I have
to take a guess as to why you musta
riled up someone important we'd never do
that mmm doesn't sound like me I go at
the bottom on there well you won't hear
any complaints from me oh and if you're
headed that way would you mind doing me
a favor
we're gonna want to say yes since his
quest is actually kind of fun
okay Wanda Dorset over in sickbay tell
her the shipments not in yet it's not
coming in anytime soon and if she'd be
so obliged to get off my ass about it
okay
much appreciated is there anything else
that can help you with and we could just
get out of here yeah okay so that line
he said about the to pay grades yeah
that's really that's one of the
interesting things like taking NPCs and
almost how do you find the moments to
give their character character and also
we just we keep our minds open like as
we're writing there's a part of us
thinking hey is there something is there
a way to express this oh it actually be
appropriate world so talking about
paygrade turning down raises you're the
kind of bureaucratic nonsense that runs
as well right when you spend enough time
writing in it you start seeing
opportunities to drop that in right we
have a lot of discussions about you know
how the world works things that are
different from our world what can we how
can we show without just straight-up
telling people the world works
differently what you're going to want to
do well this is the main quest but if we
want it if we want to do the other quest
you're gonna want to go mr. Bedford oh
yeah yeah I gotta get your ship unlocked
whose office sparkles like a Byzantium
commode
those are some words there you have it
well I'm just gonna hang in the back try
not to touch anything I was a nice touch
has something is kind of actually like
my Michael David's mustache
for years there we are has to be number
three I mean I appreciate the energy
you're coming out this way there's no
need for hysterics this is all a
hilarious misunderstanding I'm gonna let
you take care of the rest guys okay if
anything comes up that we thank you
really you really should okay yeah I'm
gonna use this because it's got the same
Internet energy as did I start off right
right you're going important places I'm
sure big exciting important places there
I've removed the flag from your ship I'm
terribly sorry for the inconvenience
well however before you go Alex promise
to tell me the location of Phineas Wells
I'm sure you've seen his wanted posters
all over the colony did Alex tell you
where Wells might be so this is your
first stop we needed to try to actually
start working for the board okay but
once again like we were saying before
making this choice does not lock you
into doing that you can play both sides
against us right that's the other for a
while yeah you could just feel free to
role play do you want to help us guy out
do you want to tell me to buzz off it's
you I'm gonna help what
Oh Oh immediately regretted that Wells I
meant smells I'm quite certain I heard
Wells
Phineas Wells God has hopes up yeah no I
mean Phineas smells but you it's always
like this with you [ __ ] freighter
captain's oh well captain be nice yes
please do
I have a federal constitutional have you
know there's bad news around I'd like to
give me a call to have your ship right
second thought maybe you should be mean
to him just a little as bit uh well once
you've tired of your jokes you know
where to find me I love the symmetry
there as if mocking him yeah I'm game
bear a mockery when we go in the medical
Bay you'll see Ellie and this is where
you could start the quest to recruit
Ellie he's arguing with the doctor here
please don't make a scene
fantastic cope yes Ellie has a lot of
style yeah she is
I believe the kids would say she's got
the drip sorry am i causing a scene
good hair as well see um forum we could
have avoided all this unpleasantness if
you just let me talk to Jessie in the
first place let me get one thing
straight
Jessie and I are not friends I just owe
her okay as for the rest I'm trying to
figure that out all I know is that she's
been here too long and she's apparently
not receiving visitors
well if you wanna if you want to pick up
the quest for later then don't exit but
if you want to just just exit out and
feel free okay
yeah everyone around the corner here dr.
okay turn around
mmm there she is oh wow my blind spot
before I take it you're a freighter
captain if you're here to better
yourself you'll have to wait I'm having
a spot of trouble with our delivery
service
[Music]
to tell you to go okay did he now
mouth on that man I swear his late
mother be ashamed well he must be
referring to Erie on I'm sure the fools
gotten himself into another scrape I'm
beginning to wonder if I'm ever gonna
get my service mechanicals at this rate
[Music]
fine I'd be grateful you'd spare the
time
we need his delivery soon is yesterday
last he told me he was taking a shortcut
by Scylla an asteroid in the Charybdis
cluster that's where I'd start where I
the adventuring type you look out there
venturing type right I think we have
entry just like with the skill system
where we try to give you multiple layers
where you can plan a very surface layer
or you could try to dig down and really
kind of work the system to get
specifically what you want it's the same
thing with our quests I mean you saw
there was a couple places where you
could have really dug down into the
story you've got a lot of information
about how the world worked and why she
actually wanted you to do this and what
was the bigger meaning of it but instead
we were just like nope give me the quest
we're out of here we want people to
really be able to play the game however
they want to play the game yeah for the
purpose of this video obviously we can't
spend here but it does very much have
that I guess I I'm trying not to make
comparisons to other games but and again
a lot of people talk about Bethesda but
this figure that there's moments where
it feels more like a Bioware game where
they're kind of like the confluence of
really strong characterization and a lot
of interesting law and narrative and
that kind of stuff makes me want to kind
of dig into characters and really talk
about him and one of the things I really
like is chatting to companions like
there's a quest early on where you can
talk to Parvati and she kind of pushes
you in a certain direction you should
speak this person to kind of get
perspective on what's going on striking
at companions there we go there is just
everyone in this game just got
phenomenal hair like who is this I just
want some bad hair really that's your
marker for a companion discussion with
the local authorities when you pass me
by I noticed your ship in port got to
thinking you might be looking for some
crew so I wandered by just to take a
closer look got to hand it to you boss
that's a fine looking ship only think
it's missing he's me wow this is awesome
let's try number two number two what you
stalking me I don't appreciate being
stalked
what no no no no okay yeah maybe a
little I'm not trying to be all
creepy-like I just want to make a good
case for myself just give me a shot
that's all I'm asking
I could be the best damn crew you ever
hired all right ah let's interview him
okay second one actually let's do that
one yep this is cool okay all right
feelings tell me why I should hire you
you're serious you're giving me a shove
you exactly all right
hang on hang on I put together a little
speech Jess you asked hey there I'm
Felix millstone I have prepared a list
of reasons why I believe you should hire
me to join the crew of your ship and or
outlaw gang I've been in this exact
interview I wanted to join a ship and/or
outlaw gang
kind of game you want I kind of want to
pick the first one go forward I'm doing
this week I am highly personable and I
get along well with anyone who is not of
the Jackass persuasion
sorry he's funny I thought you liked
since uh secondly I can't be counted on
in the event of a fire fight standoff
and/or raid my motto is if you need a
steady gun hand I'm your man that motto
is a work in progress I'm gonna let him
continue right because I want to see I
have several years of experience as a
box hauler this skill may come in handy
if you need a body dragged away or a
door held open while escaping enemy fire
conclusion thank you for considering me
for your ship crew and/or outlaw gang I
look forward to our adventures together
I thought that was real good Felix
thanks for the vote of confidence what
do you think am I in so you can hire
them I like I like the second pick the
second one there yeah I fired call
correctly this one's funny it's a very
strong pitch for himself yeah it had all
the like if you go to Google and search
for like CV like
to send recovering he's hit all the main
marks yeah so I would hire yeah I would
I would definitely you know I want to
tease him a little bit yeah fun to tease
for sure the fun kind I mean what else
do you do when you got a ship of your
own I go into Tahoe
yeah I mean I'm gonna welcome to a board
you could string along her bone if it
wait but in the end it's a yes or an
ounce but yeah you're not gonna regret
this you got a crew now Felix
it's got a very Oscar Isaacs in Star
Wars vibe town in to get some action
figures of this guy ready all right so
we've got ya just yes give him much
better we got tomorrow Felix I mean I'm
a big fan of this crew so far so um are
we going to ship yeah let's let's go
heading over to an asteroid which was
repurposed for mining right and then
abandoned but there's still things to do
there okay Gila sorry pronounced SLR
Silla Silla
Wow yeah this is impressive so this is a
straight mining operation out here
what would happen to him looks like they
started terraforming in the place but
gave up halfway
that's board's way really mm-hmm that
was nice
kind of like bit of delivery on the
background in the world through your
characters does it is it the case where
everyone who you would have bought on
here would have that information
absolutely um we're not not exactly the
same information they all kind of care
about different things we really try to
write towards their characters right so
it's not like there's one core bit of
information do you have it's always felt
through the lens of what would that
person's life experience um places in
the game where it's like I we we want to
really emphasize that this happened or
not
to have this piece of information so
they need to deliver in their own style
but a lot of ways it's a really good
interesting way to develop the
characters themselves just to show what
they care about by what they talk about
and the people are gonna point out in
the world right so felix is talking
about you know what happened here with a
because he's naturally curious and
Parvati is a little bit interested in
the tech side of things be a little bit
careful because that giant thing moving
around the distance yeah you heard her
is dangerous okay well they haven't seen
you yet but I might I'll I do a sneak
around I think I fought one of those is
and it was a quite down to the wire
so there's several of them over there so
yeah a little trouble I can't charm them
all they have no respect for Felix
either so I imagine hmm which is odd
because they have so much in common
yeah although you can't use your
companion abilities oh yeah send them
over there and have them soften what for
you I might I might that would ruin
Felix's hair and I'm only a white but
you just have to take out the outlaws
wait and listen to the conversation
first Oh God
it's always okay she can handle it
she'll be fine we might have to reload
okay Oh see if we can eavesdrop on their
conversation yeah you will they turn
about there is a lot of like ambient
chatter in this game yeah and you've got
a you've got a nice scope so you can
kind of do a lot of that we'd like to
look for emptier spaces and fill them
with ambient conversation right I think
they'll start talking yeah there we go
you know you didn't have to shoot me
down if you wanted an autograph that's a
guy we shouldn't shoot that's right you
can if you want but we think the
conversations worth waiting for the
primals find us so this I think that's
about it for that conversation just yeah
yeah they have a bunch of different
things right now they had different
times you know take them out and send
your companions in to clean up after you
I'd do a headshot for that one's going
off right there
and then you send in your companion
perfect timing to Iran's line was I've
got a daring escape buddy hey you won
this hammer is quite something
ah his trusty task it's uh that's why
you hired him right yep
that and is very compelling who I kissed
really just shrugging off my injuries as
I stroll away from another blaming
impact crater I'm getting very distinct
that brenigan vibes so that Brannigan is
one of my favorite characters of all
time to a point where I used to play
counter strike with half-life sound
selector aha and while while playing the
game I'd pumped that audio into the
games I'd be like stalled around wave
off the wave of my own men and if I did
a kill it would be like if you cowards
we're trying to explore did the voice
director kind of the character we were
going for and she didn't know we were
talking about she told them the actor
you know Futurama Zapp Brannigan's like
oh yeah I got this I'll be the judge of
that
tremendous work friend in the mirror I
was readying a daring maneuver and
you've come and save me the trouble
appears to be I'm not terrified you
bucket of bolts victory sweat victory
saw it
wonder didn't send your vision which one
will get me more conversation honest
there are ok
I swear land on ground break or even a
moment tardy and that busybodies already
been up your ass an hour
you tell her these Auto mechs are coming
and sending a hired stooge to rescue me
from certain peril only furthers my
delay no offence
pirates love bits and unlabeled meds are
worth a bundle remember you gotta guess
ah I don't know I think they all lead
somewhere I think the top level is let's
just get the show on the road
ok I've got some repairs to do
thankfully I'm a skilled mechanic as I
am a violence resolution actor not that
skilled then to the ground breaker
better late than ever I say unless
you're very late then you might consider
defaulting and skipping station those
fees will bankrupt your life advice from
captain Ariane yep alright so we have
assisted in the self rescue of canary
and clearly yeah so one of your other
companions had a little bit of
background with with him so I almost
call them zap yeah so if you if you take
them with you when you have this
conversation there's a little bit more
back and forth right are there any other
characters in the game that you've kind
of and don't name the character but
perhaps name the part of the character
that's inspired by or even the person is
inspired way not as directly I mean
think of anything that was the most
one-to-one where we just were we wanted
to do a little mini ya know I feel like
he is a bit of a not an easter egg but
an homage to drama dude I assume do you
find like play testers usually pick up
on it yes but what's very satisfying is
if you picked up on it yeah and no one
ever told you that was the case yeah I
had no I've never met that character but
I was gonna but then again I am always
thinking about that friend again so yeah
that's a tough thing when you have a
character you know and they're unvoiced
you just like ok this is a small
character in the game words can put him
there then you have the character come
in and do it you're like I wish we had
like 20 more lines for this game does
the captain suffer from sex Lexia
probably but we don't discuss it well
unless you bring Ellie along unless
you're here to file an incident report
or to inquire about the bounty posting I
must kindly ask you to clear out the
Marr debts offices aren't for leisure
time nor loitering try to turn a Felix
it's it's I think it's slightly buried
you also you need to snitch for you
captain gunner Mick red just 26 hours
old the posting that is not the criminal
her allegations include several counts
of flying under the influence
carrying open alcoholic containers
failure to pay docking fees resisting
arrest and assaulting not one but two
officers
a credit man what are you doing he's BAE
I do the ad I do the top one swerving in
the air was more like it
then he crashed hard into the dock and
tumbled out of a ship and fled on foot
spilled Rizzo's violet spectrum vodka
over officer Hartley and a front of its
own considering none of us are approved
for anything higher than green spectrum
well violet spectrum a glass for every
class violet is only reserved for the
highest of the elite so yeah say you can
see why he's wanted dead or alive okay
dreadful ain't it such blatant disregard
for order it's a real problem in the
youth these days it's true enough that
he ain't particularly deadly but the
interest on each fine being compounded
as they are means he'll be paying with
his life insurance so that's a perfect
example of how life works in the outer
world they know it's they know it's not
a death sentence but you know it's only
what they're gonna collect on his fine
so so yeah go ahead and take the poster
yeah okay you had about six other
enterprising Mavericks it's only a
matter of time before someone brings
mEEMIC Reds head or is lucky lighter as
proof of kill I do hope you're the lucky
hunter though good luck and skip speed
to you all right got ourselves in your
quest I'll say it go to the top one just
for sufficient cause for infraction in
under our jurisdiction I'll take your
statement and open an investigation into
the matter now then what's happened
there you go Oh so we can snitch on
feely yeah this is slapped his Foreman
with it
toss balls do you know the giant club is
carrying her all right come on boss I
told you he was slandering my Ranger you
finally did it huh
good for you well been a long time
coming yeah you done hauling crates then
my box hauling days are officially
behind me
say hello to Felix millstone spacer
extraordinaire
yeah yep I'd sooner shake the kids and
ton of insulin seems like every line I
can have the a sore ass I need to get
this in writing don't push your luck
millstone
I still got a cell with your name on it
so when you obviously when you pick up
companions who have lived in a certain
place or like there's a companion that
lives on monarch the monster planet well
you've seen her in two other videos
Nyoka when you go around her people are
always talking to her and saying oh hey
you know what's going on so it's it's a
really interesting way of helping to
develop the world right and similarly
like the early game that has been shown
previously quite focused on poverty as a
character yeah yeah yeah she has stakes
in the world which is an interesting way
census since this is the ground breaker
uh you see some good conversation you'll
see a fair bit of go to the election you
go through that door and we're gonna
talk to the moon man a little bit all
right
the moon man that's an interesting every
day I love so yeah is this theater
that's on the loading screens kinda
sorta this is a this is doctor Wow yep
some some distinct yoko taro vibes from
this guy as well oh it's my hey Martin
still wearing the Hat how observant I'm
authorized to state that this uniform is
more than a headgear it's a state of
mind and our customers know the
difference oh and it's not the best
choice it's spacers joy this guy he's
under pinnings afraid um look at my eyes
he's painfully sad oh well sometimes I
forget
but that face is gonna haunt me ask him
about the Hat a little bit we don't need
to go defense yeah satisfy headgear
related inquiries please send any
complaints to our consumer care and we
complain about that you know came to say
so
almost as stellar as spacers choice is
affordable wait can I get that hi we
never ask why anyone can be a spacers
choice consumer relations choice but
well I can't he's between your life
serving his job and also please help me
staring into the void can you see in
there I can see all on the top quality
merchandise in here
yeah we can we can get out of here we'll
leave people to you can talk with Martin
about the hell that is his existence for
a long time but we don't run that right
now go to the right your yeah it goes
straight through there on the backside
of that big tower in the middle there is
a elevator down to where Nick red is a
bounty ah the idea one idea where the
name McCready coming from is there a
story there is just like if you open up
your cross log for a second Wow
so here's another example of our
companions having something to say
relative - yes content is Felix and
Coretta are so should we she's telling
where the name comes from
yes we've revealed that Easter Egg
excusive reveal that go for it alright
so our quest names come from old pulp
sci-fi titles right so the the bounty
quest for Mick red is who goes there
which is the name of the original story
that the thing was based on oh and cure
kurt wrestles Russell's name and the
thing was McCready oh okay deep for that
one
okay that's a that is a deep cut but I
appreciate it very much
he's very much on drugs look at this
piece of meat just sizzling on the grill
chops
yum yum time to feed the flames it's
nothing personal
promise first I'm gonna hey Felix look
everyone its Felix your lordship good to
see you again
is this a nice man a friend of yours
Felix seeing you here feels like old
times
now what brings you down to my Spratt
infested broom closet of a kingdom so if
you have Felix with you you can kind of
talk him into handing over his lighter
and just resolve until a week just shoot
the guy or you could get the lighter to
show how it's done and then you could
shoot it if you want to go with combat
okay I thought the second one there's a
bounty on your head I wanna clean though
listen to the fire those convictions
this one's hungry for justice driver
dead rare or medium what's it gonna be
well how do you want me Cook County
Hunter Lee does have a flamethrower yeah
yeah so this is why we took dialog no
Ryan not personally your providers give
me a lighter medium world all right
let's go for this my flame
little flick here got me started on the
pyro path fine he's yours give him a
good home well that's early wasn't too
keen on the thought of coming to blows
with you you're gonna be discipline
don't worry mr. McCready
we'll treat mr. Flint extra nice on
account of he's your friend I'll miss my
baby pyro but it beats losing my head
this court needs its king and I'm one of
a kind there you go
oh wait go to the go to the top one way
toast me on it Oh keen eyes you got
there
sunita gave me this lighter and gave me
this life we had a carnal understanding
a few years back and she wanted me to
have something to remember by mcreddin
is this another one of those situations
we are confusing reality with a mushroom
trip mushrooms put the allottee
in reality Felix without mushrooms it's
all just unreal
I feel like we should kill him yeah yes
yeah just leave whenever you're ready
I'm ready yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna be
particularly cruel I'll make Felix still
there you go the first blow down Felix
[Music]
thank you this this fight can get a
little hairy this looks like you might
have to retreat I'm gonna give it do it
what what's a difficulty level are you
playing on I believe this is medium
normal normal cliche all right yeah you
should be fine normals we kind of people
who are more hardcore players we kind of
direct towards difficult right normals
more for general play and of course
stories mode is for walking your way
through Colorado that's yeah you're good
to go good have uh persuaded McBride to
hand over his lighter and and shot him
anyway yep
well I see axe hiding technically
shooting my short the people around him
that's right it was Felix um because I
just feel that was out of control I
hired this guy he drop-kicked which is
yeah if you want to go back to turn the
quest to Sunita up at the front they're
powerful that right up there and or a
stalker yeah there you go
nothing excessive mind you but the
scoundrel deserves a light beating at
least oh yeah we gave him a light be
it's fine
[Music]
don't you yeah go though yeah I'm gonna
go that one yeah you don't have to tell
her yeah but I won't hold it against you
the lighters enough to file for the
insurance payment long as his fees are
cleared I'll call it justice so let's
call it that yeah here's the bounty
payout top kick justice with any luck we
can hire more sharp-eyed bounty hunters
like you wondering if you can get into
the back and forth now how's the back
and forth with I think that might only
happen if he's not dead between Felix
Felix giving her a hard time for Rosalie
herm the cred having sex right but he's
dead yeah yeah but there you go that's
um yeah nice just kind of just scratch
the surface on what you can really do
yeah sure well thank you guys so much
for coming to show off the game I think
we've got a really good showcase of some
of the characters and the kind of effort
that you've put into kind of crafting
the world and making sure that people
always engage within the game huge fan
of desert brenigan reference I think
that's gonna be my lead for any time I
discuss it you know in this game and
also the thing reference as well yeah
I'm sure there's plenty of more of that
to kind of dig into for players yeah but
yeah when is the game out guys October
25th yeah so can't wait check it out if
you're interested and for more coverage
on the outer worlds keep it gamespot.com
[Music]